et puis sur le web maintenant les
responsables du prix nobel qui ont eu du
mal à joindre certains des lauréats dans
l'organisation pour l'interdiction des
armes chimiques entre autres et bador
est-ce qu'ils ont finalement a réussi à
les contacter écoutez ils ont eu un peu
de mal à les contacter on peut voir ici
l'organisation loyat c'est un peu leur
vidéo sur youtube ils ont eu du mal à
les contacter les gens du nouvel pour
leur remettre leur prix ils ont eu du
mal à l'aller à les appeler il était
visiblement très occupé et ils ont
essayé de les rejoindre sur twitter par
exemple pouvait voir l'organisation du
prix nobel qui on demandait à loyat
c'est de les contacter sur twitter il a
envie qu'ils auront laissé des messages
à leur bureau et leur demandent de leur
passer un coup de fil il semble que ça a
pris quand même un peu de temps mais
finalement ils y sont arrivés le ring
bonne nouvelle finalement l'organisation
du prix nobel ils ont confirmé qu'ils
avaient réussi à avoir leur
traditionnelle entrevue téléphonique
avec le lauréat ou l'orgue
l'organisation qui a gagné ce prix nobel
l'organisation vous savez que ça qui
compte 189 membres dans le monde et ils
vont bientôt on comptait 190 parce que
la syrie va les rejoindre
évidemment face à toutes ces nouvelles
même si elle les gens du prix nobel ont
réussi à rejoindre l'eau eyath et vient
les journalistes ont eu un peu de mal et
d'ailleurs louis gasset a tenu à
s'excuser toujours sur son compte
twitter ils ont dit que à cause
d'événements inattendus aujourd'hui ne
pouvait pas répondre à tous les appels
des médias
voilà et puis il ya également les prix
nobel de littérature qui semble s elle a
même été encore plus difficile à joindre
cessa alice munro qui habitent ce qui
est canadienne qui habite en colombie
britannique et qui a 82 ans était jeudi
elle a reçu le prix nobel pour la
littérature et ils ont eu beaucoup de
mal à rejoindre en fait ils sont passés
par sa fille ont réussi à contacter sa
fille qui a réussi à réveiller sa maman
qui elle dormait et qui disait qu'elle
avait complètement oublié que c'était le
jour du prix nobel
une erreur qui aurait pu dû tout un
doublé qui aurait pu lui coûter cher
parce que quand même elle va recevoir
une bourse de 1 me
le croisions de dollars les montants qui
leur seront versés d'ailleurs au moins
au mois de décembre lors d'une cérémonie
qui aura lieu la finale ment sur les
lieux du pin austère qui n'ont pas
oublié leur avenir merci